Pour Brut, je vais vous raconter l’histoire
de Dayana Yastremska.
C’est une joueuse de tennis
ukrainienne professionnelle
et elle est arrivée à Lyon
avec sa petite sœur de 15 ans, Ivanka.
C’est leur père qui a pris la décision
de les faire venir.
Elles, elles voulaient rester en famille.
Aujourd’hui, elles ne savent pas
quand elles pourront retourner en Ukraine.
Le seul moyen qu’elles ont
pour avoir des nouvelles de leurs parents,
ce sont des visios
ou des appels téléphoniques.
Leur histoire, c’est celle
de plusieurs milliers d’Ukrainiens,
qui ont fui l’offensive russe
et qui ont décidé de quitter l’Ukraine
du jour au lendemain.
Après plus de 24 heures de trajet en voiture,
en bateau et en avion,
elles finissent par arriver à Lyon.
Après Lyon,
Dayana et Ivanka vont enchaîner les tournois,
mais elles ne savent toujours pas
quand est-ce qu’elles reverront leur famille
et où elles habiteront
dans les semaines et dans les mois à venir.
J’espère que ce documentaire
vous aura intéressés.
Et si vous voulez voir d’autres reportages,
c’est sur la page YouTube de Brut.
N’hésitez pas à me laisser des commentaires,
je les lirai.
Je vous dis à bientôt !